with just days to go until the german
election on sunday outgoing chancellor
angela merkel has hit the campaign trail
with her would-be successor armin lashit
it is the last minute bid to boost his
popularity with voters
merkel and lashit visited the
northeastern city of strausend where
merkel first won her bundestag seat back
in 1990.
now after 16 years as chancellor
merkel remains very popular in germany
in contrast lashit who wants to take
over the top job
has struggled to connect with voters
he's badly in need of a boost
and let's get more now we are joined by
political correspondent anja koch anya
how much of a boost could markle give
lashed especially at this late stage in
the campaign
well the cdu is certainly hoping that it
will be a boost
for amin lashed what's remarkable is
that this has been one of the very rare
appearances of angela merkel and army
lashed together
during this election campaign it hasn't
happened very often that we see that we
have seen the two of them together on
one stage angela merkel for most of the
election campaign
had stayed out of the campaign that was
met with criticism within her own party
within the cdu but also within uh from
within her sister party the csu so
angela megan now stepping up and
campaigning together for uh together
with amin lashed and for amin
certainly meant um certainly meant to
give him a boost
what is the mood anya because i mean
miracles conservatives they have edged
up a percentage point in the polls but
they're still lagging behind their main
rivals the social democrats the election
now just in four days time
are they worried
well in his public statements and
interviews mean luscious stresses that
he is still confident and that he is
optimistic that the cbu will win this
election and that he is going to be
germany's next chancellor but it is
however obvious that the party is
worried and they have all reason to be
to be honest i mean has had a very hard
time connecting with voters during the
selection campaign and when you look at
the opinion polls depending on which
poll you look at the cdu at the moment
is around 22
while the social democrats who no one
really saw as a real danger to the cdu
just months ago is polling at around 25
now that is a very small margin but it
shows you that the cdu can't be sure to
win this election and it's a really big
question in fact as to whether how much
we should read into those numbers anya
because polls show as much as 40 percent
of the electorate are still undecided a
really big number there first of all why
is that and do we have any indication in
terms of where those voters might swing
well that certainly has to do with the
rather unique situation that germany is
facing at the moment for years and
decades german voters
were used to having a chancellor who is
re-running for office
often with a so-called chancellor bonus
because some voters tend to vote
for people who they think they know well
this time it's different we are having
three candidates that have never been
chancellor before so it's kind of more
unpredictable of what to expect this is
not something that german voters
particularly like they like things more
predictable well this time they are less
predictable so it might just take voters
more time to decide political
correspondent anyakoch thank you
local candidates are also campaigning
hard to win voters especially those who
feel that they are not often listened to
dw reporter carolina machaus traveled to
offenbach in western germany where one
young social democrat is determined to
give minorities a voice in politics
so the plan is we'll take our good vibes
with us and go down to the river and try
to strike up a conversation with people
noor khauser is 21 years old
she's a member of the social democrats
and has a seat in the local council
she wants german politics to become more
diverse
hiba was born in a refugee shelter in
germany after her parents fled religious
persecution in pakistan
she lives in offenbach in western
germany
over 60 percent of the residents here
have a mixed background but only about
one in four of them has german
citizenship and the right to vote
on average they earn less than
non-immigrants
the education system is a challenge as
is the labor market
[Music]
there's a general election on september
26th are you going to vote
can i ask you what the most pressing
issues are for you in germany
the man answers in turkish one of
hibba's colleagues translates
we are blue collar workers we want our
salaries to reflect price increases
groceries have become more expensive so
our salary should rise too
are you voting for spd
the conversations on the street continue
i grew up here i'm from offenbach but i
can't vote because i only have a turkish
passport yeah it means decisions are
made and you can't really have a say
i think it sucks to be honest
what's your name
hippa do you say it like that
with b
in germany over 10 million residents
don't have german citizenship and so
don't have the right to vote in the
federal election although they live work
and pay taxes here and those who have
the right to vote often don't one reason
for that is a very one-sided election
campaign
the problem is always that people aren't
reached out to that's not often done
many speak to a very specific group who
they think are the ones who definitely
have the right to vote it's mainly white
people who they approach but for example
no attention is paid to people who look
like me but you can see that the
conversation works when you talk to
people they're open to it and share
their problems
it's raining outside so the group takes
a break
many here believe that racism can only
be countered if politics is more open to
immigrants
you do something for society you really
involve yourself you're politically
engaged still you always hear people say
wow you're german is really good
i can stand it for one or two days but
every day it's really hurtful i remember
very well what hiber went through too
that you're devalued just because you
look different
there have been situations where people
have told me i won't vote a foreigner
like you into parliament
despite the odds hibetune newark hauser
made it into offenbach's local
parliament
now she wants more people from ethnic
minorities to get a voice in the german
bundestag